I'm saying this
and I'm saying that reading your minds
here I'm saying everything
I'm too close you know it doesn't feel
right here the package doesn't feel
right to get around so what you're doing
is you're trying to get around them and
then oh I've got him now
so
you're destroyed at the most crucial
point so you come in here
I started I've talked about the job I
mean all I was saying was
you've got to know that if your hits
I'm saying this one if you're hip
returning
so it should something up here
I don't mean something so if this
is just sort of
straight like
it was all over the way because I'm
turning my hips
it's spiraling
that arm as well because I've got a fine
space for this arm it's no good getting
up here and going right I'll get around
it somehow
because this you're not
foreign
but it's not going to just turning that
I'm going to come I come in but as soon
as I come in I've got to be weak
somewhere but not weekly mine but we in
giving up the body somewhere in the body
that causes a reaction
and massage
but what's this this this Turbo
but this hand is fully turned here
31 uh Joseph
before you turn there
so I'm doing things that
have been putting my body naturally
through doing weapons by jitsu
you're leaving your hand in your fixed
position
around there and take it again this is
doing nothing now
that's not having fears feelings
when you make some think
you know you third downs and above you
should
really be looking at this stuff or as
you're just going to stay at whatever
level you're at
it's too slow for me
please
I've just got this
this hand isn't just blowing because
it's because this is doing this
this is this is
it's so bad
so this hand has to move
technically spiritually whatever you
need to enter
if that moves so must that move
so it's collapsed but in a nice way